J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: So as you
remember the first
semester we studied bonding
and molecular structure.
Then toward the end we did some
sort of thermodynamics,
which is what connects structure
to energy, which is
what determines what chemistry
will happen.
So this semester we're going to
talk about that chemistry,
about reaction mechanisms, and
about using these reactions to
do synthesis.
And we'll also do some
spectroscopy around the middle
of the semester.
So just a brief excursion
through what
we're going to be doing.
The first two quarters of the
semester are going to be on
how mechanisms are discovered
and understood in terms of
structure and energy-- what
we talked about last time.
So first we'll look naturally
enough at
the simplest reactions.
There can't be anything
much simpler than
just cleaving a bond.
But remember there's also the
possibility of making a bond
at the same time you
break a bond.
And we introduced these ideas
last semester, of course.
So we're going to start with
free-radical substitution, one
of the earlier reactions to be
studied, as you remember, in
the 1830s in France.
But we're going to use it to
talk about the concepts of
reactivity and selectivity--
when you can get different
products, how do you control
or predict which ones
you'll get?
Then the nice thing about free
radicals is they're not
charged, so they're relatively
insensitive to solvent.
So you can just think about
the molecules themselves
reacting, whether it's in the
gas phase or solution, more or
less the same thing.
But it's quite different when
ions are involved either as
starting materials or
products or both.
Because then solvent effects
are very important.
So as we go from free radicals,
we're then going to
do solvent effects.
Then go on to nucleophilic
substitution reactions, which
almost always involve ions
either as starting materials
or products or both.
And going to use that as an
example of showing how people
go about proving
a mechanism.
Then we'll have the first
exam on February 2.
Then we'll go on to
electrophilic addition
reactions to alkenes
and alkynes.
You'll recognize that these
are concepts we introduced
last semester, but this time
we're going to focus on how
you know about how they work.
And we're going to talk there,
especially about the role of
nucleophiles.
You usually call these additions
electrophilic, but
there's quite often a very
important nucleophilic
component as well.
Then we'll get onto polymers and
their properties for just
a lecture or two.
And then conjugation,
aromaticity and pericyclic
reactions, which you'll
know what they are
when we get to them.
Then we'll have the
second exam.
And then we'll have an interlude
about spectroscopy
and go on to more focus
on synthesis.
So first, spectroscopy for
structure and also for
studying dynamics of molecules
and reactions.
So ultraviolet-visible
spectroscopy; electronic; IR
spectroscopy--
vibration, which we've talked
about a good deal already;
magnetic resonance imaging and
nuclear magnetic resonance.
Then on to aromatic
substitution.
And finally carbonyl chemistry
and the concepts of oxidation
and reduction.
Then we'll have the
third hour exam.
And the last quarter of the
course then will be more
having to do with carbonyl
chemistry; acid derivatives;
substitution taking place at
carbonyl group; reactivity
adjacent to the carbonyl
group; the classical
condensation reactions; then
something about carbohydrates
and Fischer's classical
proof of which
isomer is which of glucose.
And finally we'll talk about
some complex synthesis.
We'll be talking about synthetic
ideas all through
this, of both unnatural
and natural products.
Then we'll have the final.
So that's how long you
have to endure.
So at the end of last semester
we were talking about energy
and how it related to things--
that free energy determines
what can happen at
equilibrium--
and remember it was
all statistics.
And the statistics filtered
down to give us this handy
relationship at room
temperature that an
equilibrium constant is 10
to the minus 3/4 of the
difference in free energy.
Or if you're not worried about
entropy, the difference in
enthalpy in the heat
of the molecules.
So that's both energy
and entropy
the Gibbs free energy.
But there's a completely
independent question, which is
Will it happen?
You know, graphite is more
stable than diamond
as a form of carbon.
But the advertisers tell us that
a diamond is forever--
just because it's not as stable
doesn't mean it'll
convert in any reasonable
time.
So the questions of kinetics are
just as important as the
questions of equilibrium, or at
least almost as important.
And we saw last time that we
could approach this by
studying lots of trajectories,
trying to calculate how all
the atoms move in
going from one
arrangement to another one.
But that really provides
too much detail.
In fact, over the last couple of
weeks we've had interviews
from people who are applying
for a faculty position here
and a number of them are talking
about fancy new ways
of actually looking
at one molecule at
a time as it reacts.
So that you actually could do
something getting closer to
trajectories.
But really that's more detailed
than we want.
We want to summarize things
statistically to know what's
going to happen in a flask.
So we have collective concepts,
enthalpy and
entropy, and then we can have a
reaction coordinate diagram--
remember we rolled a marble on
that thing last time, on that
potential energy surface.
Or we could slice along the
potential energy surface and
look at the starting material,
the transition
state and the products.
Or we could simplify things to
notice that this is just a
sequence of three species: the
starting material which is
molecules that we know about,
the transition state which we
don't know about, and the
products which we know about.
So our challenge is going to
be to try to figure out
something about the transition
state given what we know about
the starting material and the
products, because its energy
relative to those others is
going to determine rates.
So we have then free energies
with just these three species,
rather than trying to look
at a detailed trajectory.
So free energy determines what
can happen at equilibrium, but
also how fast it happens
in kinetics.
For that purpose we need to
know what the energy is,
either the free energy or
the heat at least of the
transition state.
And remember we talked about
this last time that in
Eyring's transition state
theory, the rate constant for
the reaction per second is
10 to the 13th times that sort
of equilibrium constant between
the starting material and the
transition state.
So again, we can use at room
temperature that 3/4 delta G
when we express it in
kilocalories per mole.
So we want to use energies to
predict equilibria and also to
predict rates first
for the very
simplest one step reactions.
And no reaction is conceptually
simpler than just
breaking a bond in the
gas phase to give
atoms or free radicals.
So we need to know the
energy for that.
Now, in the textbooks that I've
handed out to you there
are tables like this
one that give
bond dissociation energies.
How much energy does is actually
take to break a bond?
This particular one is from a
text we used to use in the
course called Streitwieser
and Heathcock.
That was in 1993, but as of
2003 there's a new set.
And you can see that
these don't change
very much in time--
98 became 99, 111 became 113.
Some of them are a
little bigger--
81 became 85, and so on.
And these values I refer
to as Ellison's.
I mentioned him last
semester--
there's Barney Ellison.
He and his friends compiled
these new values, and he's
going to come and talk to you
about how he did this
in April some time.
He can't get out of Boulder
now-- he's all snowed in out
there, Colorado.
So this is his table of
molecular bond dissociation
energies for losing
H from something.
RH becomes R plus H atom--
R radical plus H atom.
So these are experimental
bond enthalpies.
And as you can see, some of them
are known to very high
precision, like H2 is known to
six significant figures.
Most of them, of course, aren't
known that well, but
most of the ones in this table
are known pretty darn well,
plenty accurately enough
for our purposes.
Let's see if we can understand
some of these so that we don't
have to memorize the table.
Let's look at the bonds
from H to halogen.
You'll notice as we go down to
larger halogens from fluorine,
chlorine, bromine, iodine,
we go from 136 to
103 to 87 to 71--
quite a difference in
the energy involved.
So the idea is that larger
halogens don't overlap as well
with the hydrogens, so they
don't make as strong a bond at
their normal bond distances.
And there's less electron
transfer to the halogen.
So whereas HF looks like that
and the two electrons are
lowered quite a bit, in HI the
net amount of lowering of the
electrons in forming the bond
isn't nearly as much.
So that makes sense to us.
So less electron stabilization
means a weaker bond.
Now here's the Table 2, which
is bond enthalpies for
various atoms or groups
attached to various
hydrocarbon radicals.
Previously we looked at H
attached to halogen, now we're
looking at methyl attached to
halogen and you see there's a
very similar trend.
It's strongest for fluorine,
weaker for chlorine, weaker
still for bromine, and
weakest for iodine.
So many of the same features.
But let's try to understand
different radicals.
So we're going to look at the
bonding of H to methyl, ethyl,
isopropyl and t-butyl.
And the first thing you notice
about this is that they're all
almost the same.
As we went down the halogens
it varied by 60
kilocalories per mole.
But as we go across these
different methyl, ethyl,
isopropyl, t-butyls, they're all
100 kilocalories per mole,
plus or minus 5.
We're going to look next lecture
at this in some more
detail and see if we
can understand why
they vary at all.
But they don't vary very much.
On the other hand, some
hydrocarbon radicals have
substantially different ones,
like vinyl and allyl, phenyl
and benzyl.
The vinyl and phenyl are
much stronger, 10
kilocalories stronger.
The benzyl and allyl are about
10 kilocalories weaker.
So let's see if, based on what
we did last semester, we can
understand why this
might be so.
Are these unusual bond
dissociation energies to be
explained as unusual bonds,
that is the bonds are
unusually strong or weak?
Or is it the radicals are
This is compared to what?
We have the starting material
and go to the products where
the bond is broken,
we go uphill in
energy by these amounts.
The question is are things
unusual because the starting
bond is weak or unusually
strong?
Or is it because the radical
is unusually stable or
unusually unstable?
Compared to what?
So let's look at a couple of
these cases and see if we
could understand.
First let's look at vinyl, which
is the H attached to a
carbon that's double bonded.
Now if we look at the radical we
see that we have a SOMO, so
there's the possibility for
interacting with something and
changing its energy.
But notice that the HOMOs and
LUMOs that it might interact
with are pi and pi-star.
And there's no special
stabilization because they're
perpendicular to one
another, they're
orthogonal, there's no overlap.
So there's no reason that having
this double bond should
make that radical unusually
stable.
And notice that, it, in fact,
is hard to break as if this
were unstable.
But it's neither stable
or unstable, it's
just what it is.
On the other hand, if we look at
the starting material where
we have this C-H bond, notice
that as compared to these
others, which are 100 plus or
minus 5, that this one is made
from an sp squared carbon,
right?
So very good overlap.
So in this case, it's that
the bond is unusual.
The bond is unusually
strong, the
radical is nothing special.
It's very hard to break.
So it's hard, it's 111.
The same thing is true in the
phenyl radical where, again,
the C-H bond we're talking about
is attached to a double
bonded carbon.
Here it's part of
a benzene ring.
But again, the unusual energy
orbitals in the ring are
perpendicular, they don't
overlap with the singularly
occupied orbital we're
talking about.
Therefore, nothing
special here.
But again, it's an sp squared
carbon to hydrogen bond, and
again, it's unusually strong,
113 kilocalories per mole.
So these are unusual because the
starting material has an
unusually strong bond.
Now let's look at these others,
allyl and benzyl where
it's an unusually easy
bond to break.
Now we look at the allyl radical
where we've broken H
off this carbon, and now what's
different about that as
compared to the ones above?
We broke the H off, we
got a p orbital that
has the single occupancy.
Anybody got an idea about
whether it's going to be usual
or unusual?
Sebastian?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
STUDENT: It can mix
with the pi-star?
PROFESSOR: Now it can mix with
the pi-star because it's going
in and out of the plane.
So now it overlaps with
the pi and pi-star.
Now what's that going to do?
Well here's the singly
occupied
orbital, the red one here.
Here's pi-star, vacant.
They'll mix.
That would suggest that
the single electron
would go down in energy.
That would be good.
However, we should also think
about the fact that there's an
unusually high HOMO associated
with the blue orbitals there,
the pi orbital.
So we could consider
instead the pi.
And now we see that that would
shift this electron up, but
these two electrons
would go down.
Again you would win
more down than up.
So this is a little
schizophrenic on the part of
the singly occupied
orbital.
Does it move up or down?
The answer is "No."
One of them pushes it down, the
other pushes it up, stays
the same place it started.
But the others go up and down,
the ones that came from the pi
and the pi-star.
So you get net stabilization due
to this pair of electrons
going down.
So we have this special
"allylic" it's called,
stabilization from mixing the
SOMO with the pi and pi-star
orbitals adjacent
to one another.
So this radical is
unusually stable.
On the other hand, in the
starting material, the bond
was just a regular old sp3 C-H
bond, nothing special there.
So as compared to here where
the starting material was
unusually strong, here the
product is unusually stable.
So that was easy to break,
89 kilocalories per mole.
And the same is true for the
benzyl radical where the p
orbital on the adjacent carbon,
again can overlap with
the pi system of the
benzene ring.
So you get special stability
and it only takes 90
kilocalories per mole.
So we can understand these
special cases of bond
strengths, of bond enthalpies.
Now, we spoke last semester
about the
halogenation of alkanes.
So we can use these bond
dissociation energies to do
some calculations about the
possibility of doing
halogenation of alkanes.
So let's just take as an example
methane, some various
dihalogen molecules, and we can
trade partners, a double
displacement sort of reaction,
as they called it in the early
days, and make CH3
X and HX.
So we break the red bonds and
form the green bonds.
So we have a cost to pay in
breaking bonds, we have a
return from making the bonds,
and we're going to see whether
we get a net profit from trying
to run this operation.
So we're going to do it for
fluorine, chlorine, bromine
and iodine.
Now, of course, in all those
cases the C-H bond is the
same, it's 105 kilocalories
per mole.
Now, but the halogen-halogen
bonds are different.
It's fairly weak for fluorine,
strong for chlorine, but then
weaker again for bromine,
and back to
the start for diiodine.
What does that tell you that as
you go down the rows of the
periodic table, you don't get
some monotonic up or down in
the bond strength, but
it goes up and down?
What do you infer from
that kind of thing
when you get curve?
STUDENT: There must be two
factors.
PROFESSOR: There must
be at least two
factors involved in this.
And those factors are probably
the overlap of the sigma bond,
which is best for
fluorine-fluorine, but the
interaction of unshared pairs
which is worst for fluorine.
So you have two things
going on.
Anyhow, we can add those two
together to see what it's
going to cost us to break
those two bonds.
And there are the values,
they're in the range of 150
kilocalories per mole.
But then when we do the reaction
we're going to profit
by making the bonds on the
right, so that we have various
values for the carbon-X bond
that we got out of that table
we just showed.
And for the H-X bond, and
there's the return we get.
Now are these going to be
favorable reactions?
Well, in the case of fluorine
it's wildly favorable.
It's favorable by 109
kilocalories per mole.
But it's only 19 kilocalories
per mole for chlorine, only 9
for bromine, and it's 12
kilocalories UPHILL in that
case of iodine.
So you're not going to make a
profit if you try to set up a
factory to convert methane
and iodine to
methyl iodide and HI.
In fact, you'd want to run at
the opposite direction.
But the others, at least
overall, are favorable.
So we know from equilibrium
now that for three of the
halogens this reaction
should be favorable.
And for one of them it should
be unfavorable.
But how about the rate?
How fast will it be?
Now if this were the mechanism,
first you break two
bonds, then you change partners
and re-attach,
the activation energy for
getting up to the transition
state for this where both bonds
are broken is going to
be this cost. Right? So is
break-two-bonds-then-make-two a
plausible mechanism?
Could we get a rate that's
reasonable on
the basis of that?
If you know the activation
energy you have to get to, how
do you go about calculating
the rate?
Debby?
STUDENT: 10 to the 13th.
PROFESSOR: Right, it's 10 to
the thirteenth per second,
times 10 to the--
STUDENT: Negative 3/4th
PROFESSOR: 10 to the minus
3/4 of that energy.
So let's think about it
then in this case.
Suppose we take one of these
that's about 140.
So at room temperature, 300K,
which is where your
approximation works, the 3/4,
we find that it's 10 to the
thirteenth per second times
10 the minus 106
3/4 of one of these numbers.
So it'll be 10 to the
minus 93 per second.
That's a very unfavorable
number.
So forget that.
There's no way a mechanism like
that could work at room
temperature.
What might you be able to do
to realize such a reaction?
Yeah, Amy?
STUDENT: Heat it.
PROFESSOR: Higher temperature.
So suppose you go to
3,000K instead of 300K?
Now instead of 3/4 it's 3/40.
So if we go to 3,000K,
then it's 10 to the thirteenth
times 10 to the minus
10.6, which would
be 250 times a second. Right?
So that would be accessible.
Except that there probably is
something else lthat could
happen when you're at that
very high temperature.
So fundamentally this is not
a reasonable mechanism.
And we already know a better
way to go about it from
looking at these potential
energy surfaces for
transferring an atom between two
other atoms. Remember we
start with H plus H2, and then
we can move around on this
surface and have, for collinear
three Hs, we can
get the energy differences
between two of the Hs and the
other two Hs.
So there's the product we want
to go to where a hydrogen has
been transferred from the
right to the left.
And one way to do it, the way
we've been talking about, is
to go by way of three separate
atoms. Which means we go up
there, way up in energy, very
slow, and once we get there
then zing, we go down.
But it's very hard to get
up to this plateau.
On the other hand, as we knew
from the marble, the way it
actually works is to transfer a
hydrogen between two rather
than to break a bond first
and then make a bond.
So make it as you break it that
way and that's going to
be much faster.
So this kind of displacement
reaction is the way we want to
do it-- to make a new bond
as we break the old one.
That's how we're going to do
it, and we already talked
about this last semester.
First you take chlorine and
you break its bond.
That's going to require
some energy.
But once you have the free
radical, then you can transfer
a hydrogen atom making a bond
as you break a bond.
So going through that
pass rather than
over the big plateau.
And now the product of that
is HCl, one of the
products you want.
But the other one is another
free radical made without
having to spontaneously
break a bond.
And now it can react with Cl2
to give the other product we
want and the chlorine atom,
and then we go back
to the beginning in this
free-radical chain, and this is
what we talked about
last semester.
Ok, another way of
writing the same thing
is to say we could have the
starting materials here
to the top left and bottom
right, the halogen and
the alkane, and we could have
the X atom that we got somehow.
It could be by heat breaking the
relatively weak bond, it could
be by light, it could be by some
chemical reaction that generates
a free radical, but somehow we
get a radical.
Then it could react
in a hydrogen
atom transfer to give one of the
products, the green XH here,
and another radical, and it
could react with the halogen
to give the other product and go
back where we started.
So what we have is a cyclic
machine that just cranks round
and round. It preserves the
radicalness of the situation.
You don't have to break any new
bonds spontaneously--
only to get the first radical.
We're going to talk about this
some more later on.
But to look now at how we're
going to rearrange things--
if you want to have a mechanism
for a reasonable
rate, what you're going to do is
trade two of these columns.
Instead of breaking two and then
making two, we'll trade
those two columns so that on the
left we make and break; on
the right in Step 2
we make and break.
So now when we look at how much
each of these takes,
Step 1 now in the case of
fluorine is actually favorable.
Step 2 is wildly favorable
in the case of fluorine and
overall it's very favorable,
as we knew.
But now you can see that these
others, although overall
favorable, one of the steps
is unfavorable, but not
drastically unfavorable--
only 2 or 10 or 20 kilocalories
per mole.
That kind of barrier
you could get over.
You can't get over the
barriers of 50
kilocalories or more.
So now you have two steps, each
of them a very simple
make as you break
atom transfer.
And, of course, here the first
one is so high that you're not
going to be able to get over it,
and even if you could you
wouldn't give the product, the
reaction would run backwards.
So we know the energies of the
starting material and products
for each of these steps, but
we don't really know the
activation energy-- how much
you have to come up
before you come down.
And that's what we're going to
be starting to look at next
lecture is how could we predict
the activation energy
for a simple one-step reaction
if we know how exothermic or
endothermic it is.
But even if we could predict the
rate of Step 1 or step 2,
there's still a problem
because the overall process is
not just one step,
it's two steps.
And how would we know the
overall rate if there are two
reaction steps going on?
This is a little more
complicated.
So we're going to take a little
digression now to learn
to cope with complex reactions
that involve several steps.
So this is a digression
on reaction
order and complex reaction.
Now the reaction order is the
kinetic, the rate analog of
the law of mass action that we
talked about at the end last
time-- remember, it was just
statistical, how likely is it
that there are going to be two
things next to one another?
The same thing, getting next
to one another is the same
problem if things are going to
react with one another in
getting to the transition
state as well.
So there's going to be a
dependence of rate on
concentration, the same way that
equilibrium depends on
concentrations, as we
saw last semester.
Moreover, this dependence of the
rate on concentration can
give us information about what
kind of mechanism the reaction
might be undergoing.
So that's why we're particularly
interested in it.
Now just to look at some simple
ideas first. The rate
is how much per second, say, or
per minute or hour a day or
whatever, how much per second.
So we could have a faucet, we
turn it on and the water comes
out a certain rate per second.
Now what would happen if
you had two faucets?
Well, if things were simple
the rate would double.
You know, if you think carefully
about it, it won't
quite do that because there
might be a restriction in how
much water can get to
the two faucets.
But in a simple point of view
if you double the number of
faucets, you double the rate.
There's another way of doubling
the rate, which is to
use a bigger faucet, one that's
twice as big, twice the
cross-sectional area.
Now in chemistry we can look at
how many moles or molecules
we get per second.
And if we have one beaker and
then have another beaker, or a
single beaker with twice the
volume, we double the rate.
So that will double the rate.
But chemists are clever.
They can not only change the
volume, they can also change
the concentration in the same
volume, and that's the
question we have. Obviously
you'd expect it to get faster
if you have more stuff,
but how much faster?
Will it double?
So this has to do with what
are called rate laws.
What that exponent is going to
be that says if you double the
concentration of a reagent, how
much will the rate change,
the number of molecules
you get per second?
So the rate is the increase
in product with time.
Then there's a rate law that's
some constant times the
concentration of something.
And maybe several
concentrations, but that
question mark is
the exponent--
what power do we raise it to?
That's what we mean in talking
about the kinetic order.
If it's to the zeroth power,
it's a zeroth order; first
power, first order; second
power, second order and so on.
But those exponents will have to
do with what the mechanism
of the reaction is.
So the only way to discover
it is by experiment.
So let's first look at some
simple one-step reactions, and
then we're going to look at
complicated reactions.
So in a simple
one-step  reaction you
could have zero order--
this sounds weird, doesn't it?
That the rate doesn't depend on
how much material you have.
You double the amount of
material, double the
concentration of material and
it doesn't change the rate.
How can that be?
Well here's a picture that
helps illustrate it for
sheep getting from
one field to the other.
Now in this situation, if the
shepherd had more sheep, would
the rate increase?
Would you get sheep from one
field to the other faster?
No, they're going as fast as
they can no matter how many
sheep are lined up.
Because it's saturated.
It can't go any faster
because of how wide
he's opening the gate.
So there are real cases like
this in chemistry where you
have a catalyst that's involved
in converting the
starting material
to the product.
When the catalyst is working
as fast as it possibly can,
increasing the starting material
isn't going to
increase the rate of the
reaction anymore.
The gate can't open any wider.
And that's often the
case with enzymes.
So you have the substrate, the
starting material, which
interacts with the catalyst
in order to get a product.
But if the catalyst is rate
limiting, if it's saturated,
you can't go any faster.
So the rate then is proportional
to how much
catalyst you have, of course.
If you doubled the amount
of catalyst under those
situations you'd double
the rate.
But the substrate is raised to
the zero power, it doesn't
make any difference.
So the rate is actually just
proportional to the catalyst,
independent of the substrate.
But if doing the experiment you
didn't realize that there
was a catalyst in there doing
it, you just thought it was
happening spontaneously, then
you would say it's zero order.
So that's a zero order reaction,
zero order kinetics.
But that works only when the
sheep are really crowded here.
If the sheep were all over the
fields and some coming
through, if the concentration
were lower, then having more
sheep would allow them to
get through faster.
You're not saturating the
catalyst. But it becomes first
order in substrate when you have
very low concentration of
substrate, but at some higher
concentration it
becomes zero order.
So it's always, in principle,
possible to lower the
concentration until it
becomes first order.
But, in fact, under many
conditions it would be
zero order.
So that's an example
of zero order.
Now, first-order says the rate
is proportional to the first
power of the amount of
reagent you're using.
And that's, of course, very
reasonable-- it's like the
water coming through the taps
or something like that.
Now if you have first order
kinetics, the amount of
product you get in time
looks like this.
It's an exponential approach
to the 100%.
Or this particular one
is drawn with a
certain rate constant.
If the rate constant
were faster it
would rise more quickly.
If the rate constant were
lower it would rise more
slowly, but always it would
go, in this case, to 100%.
You could, instead of monitoring
the product, you
could look at the disappearance
of starting
material, which is then an
exponential decay, just the
same thing upside-down.
So exponential decay
means you have a
constant, so-called half-life.
Now I chose 0.69 here
for a reason.
It's because the half-life, the
time it takes for half the
material to go away, is 0.69
divided by whatever k is.
So if I chose k to be 0.69,
the half-life is 1.
So after 1 second, half of
the material remains.
After another 1 second,
a quarter, then an eighth, then
a sixteenth and so on.
And that's the necessary--
you can prove it easily
by mathematics for
a first-order reaction.
There is a repeating
half-life.
Now, suppose you have a more
complex situation where it's
first-order kinetics but
it's reversible.
So the starting material at a
certain rate goes to product,
but the product can also come
back to starting material,
suppose at a much lower rate.
So once you reach equilibrium
the two rates balance so
things cease changing.
In fact, you know, in the
nineteenth century,
equilibrium situations were
initially discussed not as
equilibria, but as
balanced rates.
So at any rate, they're
the same thing.
So whatever k1 is times the
concentration of starting
material will be equal
to whatever k-1 is times the
concentration of product.
Or we could divide through
by starting material
here and k1 over here.
So k1 over k-1 is the
equilibrium constant.
So now the product doesn't go
to 100% nor the starting
material to zero.
But if you start with all
starting material, you get
these exponential behaviors,
it's still exponential.
That's what's interesting.
But it doesn't approach zero.
So here, after 1 second where
with that rate constant you
would have fallen to half, you
don't fall quite to half,
because some stuff
is coming back.
But if you go to the ultimate
goal of equilibrium
here, then you find--
notice the equilibrium constant
is 3, I chose that to
be a third of that.
So there's one quarter of the
red material and three
quarters of the blue material
at equilibrium.
But if we draw this at 25%, the
value that the starting
material actually approaches
asymptotically, exponentially,
we find now there is a
repeating half-life--
this is truly an exponential.
But the interesting thing is
that it's an exponential decay
to the equilibrium mixture,
but the half-life is 0.69
divided by the SUM of the
two rate constants.
Again, this is easy to
demonstrate using calculus,
but it's just sort of cute
that you add forward and
reverse rate constants together
to get how rapidly it
approaches equilibrium.
So they're first-order
reactions, both just one way
and reversible.
Now, a second-order reaction
is proportional to
the square of [A].
That's obviously true if two
A's have to get together in
order to reach the
transition state.
But it could also be
second-order if you have an A
interacting with a B. In that
case you say it's first order
in A and first-order in B and
second-order overall.
But what if B is effectively
constant?
So as time goes on, A is
decreasing but B is not
decreasing.
How could that possibly
be the case?
How could you have a reaction
where B doesn't decrease?
STUDENT: B is a catalyst.
PROFESSOR: Ah, if B
were a catalyst,
it doesn't get consumed.
That's one way.
Another way is that the B is in
gross excess compared to A.
So even though A consumes a
B, it doesn't change its
concentration appreciably,
because the concentration is
so large compared to that of A.
So if [B] is much greater
than [A] you get that.
And in that situation you say
that you can neglect [B]
by incorporating
it into the k.
Whatever [B] is, it's
not changing.
For all you know when you're
doing the experiment you might
not even though there's a
catalyst there, but it's there
in always the same amount,
you always get
the same rate constant.
And in a situation like
that you say it's
pseudo first order.
It behaves as if it's first
order, even though it really
depends on something
else as well.
And so a second-order process
could be a pseudo first order
rate constant.
For example, suppose
B were the solvent.
Then it appears that it's a
first-order reaction, even
though it turned out that the
solvent had to react with the
thing in order to do it.
So that's pseudo first order.
Now, if you have a second-order
reaction compared to a
first-order reaction, that
is a regular second-order
reaction where two molecules
of A have to get together,
what you find is that a
first-order reaction
goes like this.
But the second order starts
faster and ends slower.
So it's no longer exponential.
Obviously it's decreasing but
not with a half-life, not
exponentially, not a repeating
half-life because it gets
slower as it goes along because
it depends on the
square of the concentration.
So it slows faster.
It's not exponential.
There is no constant
half-life.
So that's how you
would know that
something is second order.
You measure how much in the
first increment of time, the
second increment, and they're
not exponential.
Now we'll get on to complex
reactions and the idea of the
rate-limiting step.
So suppose that you go to an
intermediate and then it goes
to product.
But suppose the transition state
energies are like this.
So it's very slow to get
to the intermediate.
But once you're at the
intermediate it rapidly goes
to product.
Now this reactive intermediate
never builds up, you never
have an appreciable amount of
it, because even if it were at
equilibrium with this there's
very little of it with a big
energy difference here.
So you might not even
know that the
intermediate is there.
You get there and it immediately
goes to product.
In that case, who cares really
about what rate this is, as
long as it's fast? The rate at
which you get product is the
rate at which you get this.
It never builds up.
Every time you get it, it goes
immediately to product, or
very quickly.
So this first step then, even
though it's a two-step
reaction, the first step is
the one whose rate makes a
difference.
If you double the rate of the
first step then you'll double
the overall rate of the
reaction, because the second
step doesn't make
any difference.
So that's called the
rate-limiting step.
On the other hand, suppose that
that first reaction is
fast and the second
one is slow.
So you have a rapid
pre-equilibrium formed between
these two-- again, not very
much of the intermediate.
But it reaches an equilibrium
concentration compared to
this, or almost, and then slowly
it goes to product.
Now two things that are in
equilibrium with the same
thing are in equilibrium
with each other.
So to the extent that that
intermediate is in equilibrium
with the starting material, and
we treat the rate of going
over here as an equilibrium
between the intermediate and
this transition state, we could
also pretend that the
transition state is in
equilibrium with the starting
material, since they're both
in equilibrium with the
intermediate.
So now, who cares that there's
an intermediate, that there's
a first step.
We can calculate the rate just
on the basis of getting how
much of this transition state
there is by assuming it's in
equilibrium with that
starting material.
So now the second step or the
second transition state is
rate-limiting.
All we have to know is how high
it is compared to the
starting material.
We don't care about
the intermediate.
So you can have one step
or the other step be
rate-limiting.
Or if they're not drastically
different, both of them could
affect the rate.
Many cases one or the other
is rate-limiting.
But if you want to see how it
works out in a complicated
case, where you have a starting
material that can go
reversibly to the intermediate,
and then the
intermediate goes to
product all with
certain rate constants,
on the website you can get an
Excel program, which is a
crummy Excel program.
I'm sorry, it executes
very slowly.
You can change the parameters to
make it go a little faster.
But you can put in what energy
you want for the starting
material, the intermediate and
the product; and what energy
you want for the transition
states, one and two, and see
how the overall rate compares
with what you would have
calculated if it had been just
the first step that you had to
get over, or just the second
step that you had to get over.
In this particular case where
each of these is about between
a kilocalorie and a kilocalorie
and a half, the
difference between those two
and the difference between
these two, you get this.
So this is the actual rate.
Notice the amount of
starting material
immediately falls quickly--
that's when you're establishing
equilibrium
between these two.
So starting material is
going to intermediate.
And then slowly it
goes away as the
intermediate goes to product.
Here is the intermediate.
It immediately builds up to some
concentration and then it
changes very slowly.
It stays fairly stable for
any short period of time.
Now, if you didn't have the
first barrier and had only the
second one, it was a
one-step reaction.
This is what you would
have calculated
for those same energies.
So not too bad.
So, in fact, the second
transition state is pretty
much rate-limiting-- you get
pretty much the same result.
On the other end, if transition
state two weren't
there and you only had to get
over transition state one,
then you'd have that blue
one there, if it
were the sole barrier.
So very far from that.
But even in this situation,
you don't make a very big
mistake if you just ignored
the intermediate and
the first transition state,
and said it
was only transition state two.
It's rate limiting.
And if you fiddle with this
you'll find that if you start
changing these differences very
much, then one of them or
the other one becomes clearly
rate-limiting--
you get much better agreement.
Now, I said that this was
between a kilocalorie and a
kilocalorie and a half, 3/4 of
that is about one, so the
equilibrium ratio
is about 10--
or actually, I said 9 here,
9 times as much starting
material as intermediate.
So once the intermediate reaches
its steady sort of
equilibrium relationship with
the starting material, this
very quick rise here, once you
get there, then there's 9
times as much starting material
as there is in
intermediate.
That's 9 times as
much as this.
And that persists then,
that ratio.
When you get to here it's 9
times as much of one or the
other and so on.
Now this is also a factor
of 10 between this.
But this has to do with
rates, remember.
So this is how fast the
intermediate goes back to
starting material is 10 times
faster than how fast it goes
to product because of those
differences in the delta H of
activation.
And what that means is that once
the intermediate reaches
its steady state, its
equilibrium relationship with
the starting material, it yields
product 1/10 as fast as
it is formed.
So it forms very rapidly,
you can see that here.
But now individual molecules are
still being formed just as
rapidly, or almost as rapidly,
but they're going away just as
rapidly as they're formed.
Every one that's formed at a
certain rate goes back to
starting material 10
times for every
time it goes to product--
9 times for every time
it goes to product.
So 1/10 of the time it
goes on to product.
So now the rate of going from
starting material to product
is however fast it goes over
the first one times 1/10,
because it's not changing.
It's reached the so-called
steady state.
It's changing very slowly.
Individual molecules are
going very rapidly.
So the rate of an individual
molecule to go from starting
material to product is how fast
it goes to intermediate
times 1/10.
So that's a sequential
reaction -- the idea of the
rate-limiting step.
Now a really interesting concept
is fractional order.
But I see that we've reached the
time now, so we'll have to
wait for fractional order
until the next lecture.